muchos me preguntan si soy española o
colombiana o porque hablo así la verdad
es que siempre digo que sí para no dar
explicaciones
es por eso que hoy estoy aquí frente a
ustedes para compartirles mis razones
cuando nací me diagnosticaron hipoacusia
bilateral grave es una forma bonita de
decirle a la sordera no escucha
absolutamente
mis padres me llevaron con diferentes
doctores y muchos de ellos dijeron que
jamás iba a poder hablar que mejora
transfiera lenguaje de señas
la palabra señas es una palabra
prohibida en casa por muchos años me
llevaron a terapias de lenguaje y
aprendí a leer la voz
escuelas normales claro había profesores
que no modula van bien y no se les
entendía nada o que escribiera en el
pizarrón y dictaba
les confieso que cuando iba a fiestas
movía los labios para aparentar que me
sabían las letras de las canciones
recuerdo que era 2010 y en eso se
escucha la canción de descontrol de
daddy yankee ya sabes tu del reggaeton y
en eso al fin se acerca conmigo y me
pregunta algo al oído cholet empinada
dedique a si me sequé y me prometí al
baño
no podía pronunciar bien la cuota o la s
se reían pero como dicen a palabras
necias oídos sordos
aprendí a crear mi propio mecanismo de
defensa mejor que tiene el deporte en el
arte los libros se convirtieron en mis
mejores amigos y mis padres son unos
grandes motivadores mi padre psicólogo
frustraba y mi madre una mujer muy
práctica
cuando cumplí 15 años me pusieron un
implante coclear
que es un dispositivo de tecnología
impresionante
pero implicaba una operación 9 es cosa
al día siguiente que me conectaron
estaba durmiendo una fiesta y se
escuchaba un ruido muy extraño yo no
entendía qué era lo estaba buscando lo
estaba buscando adivinen qué era
el reloj
ya
impresionante como empecé a escuchar
nuevos sonidos como los pájaros o
incluso mi propia voz
yo no podía creerlo
sentía que había vuelto a nacer
nacer con el sistema auditivo
perfecto es un privilegio pero escuchar
con el plan es un milagro
claro aún me prendo a retos como estuve
que tengo un hachazo consciente a las
llamadas oa las películas y subtítulos y
ahora a los cubrebocas
decidí venirme desde sonora a
guadalajara estudió la carrera de
derecho
porque sabía que quería ser abogada cree
que nadie se iba a dar cuenta pero que
no
pero es decir la verdad es amistad es
increíbles que incluso en clases decían
presente por mí
pero por supuesto que para la niña no
era suficiente
decidí irme de tratar a españa y otra
vez de tu fe no entiendo por qué lo
piden si abren muy mal inglés
prisa y dicen blazer
como le dice q clic
[Música]
r
están doña que creen que me pasó
se me descompuso el plan de tres veces
tres veces por algo dice que la tercera
es la vencida
estaba
desesperada
y no solo yo
también me reuní yanina y patch
practicaba sus monólogos
era un silencio total
imagínense como si estuvieran en una
película sin sonido
empecé a observar la naturaleza
a las personas
desarrolle otra vez mis otros sentidos
conocí mi instinto de supervivencia
me pesa cuestionar
porque a mí
[Música]
para que existo
quién soy
quien quiero ser
el silencio también tiene respuestas
me perdí para volver a encontrar
me des un ep para volver a conectar
y ahora les quiero compartir tres puntos
que me ayudaban a conectar
resiliencia
imagínense que es como una carrera de
vallas y cada valla y cada adversidad es
un obstáculo tal vez te caes pero te
levantas tal vez no ganaste pero
llegaste a la meta y no sabes lo
increíble que llegaste a hacer hasta que
hay este grado
es la capacidad de hacer frente a la
presida de la vida
transformar este dolor en una fuerza
motora
pero se verá
y el amor si a veces me sentía con una
extraña sentía que no pertenecía en este
mundo
hasta que me gustó ser diferente para
que ser vasca o hablar igual si cada
persona es única e irrepetible
no hay ninguno con tu mismo adn
hay que amarse a uno mismo para amar a
otros
el amor propio de familia para dejar son
una fuente de inspiración y motivación
si no fuera por ellos yo no estaría
parada frente a ustedes
la p
les platico una historia
cuando pide misiones
había que visitar a las casas del pueblo
a mí me tocó conocer a una señora que se
llamaba marta que tenía una hijita que
se llamaba martita
y resulta ser que martita tenía
sordera también era sordomuda como
ustedes saben el oído está conectado con
el habla
les me platicó es mi historia yo le
platiqué la mía
no saben las gracias que me dio gracias
por la esperanza de que algún día su
hija podría hablar
sentí en este momento una p inés y cable
porque sabía que tenía una misión
todo tiene una razón si no este mundo no
tendría sentido
cuántas veces nos hemos desconectado
con nuestra familia con nuestra pareja o
con nuestros amigos
cuántas veces hemos sido sordos
emocionalmente con nuestro alrededor
incluso con nosotros mismos
los escuchas o sólo los oyen
escuchar es una forma de empatizar con
el otro
escuchar
es una decisión propia que humaniza en
un momento cada vez más deshumanizado
por la indiferencia
por la intolerancia
o por la ignorancia
y hoy te pregunto
y tú estás listo para conectarte
porque yo
esperé toda una vida
[Aplausos]